we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this
voicemail is warning me about something
that may destined us for failure on
twitch is that a word to destined us i
hope it is the david pakman show has
launched on twitch twitch is primarily a
live streaming platform twitch.tv slash
david pakman i've been doing a bunch of
live streams they're taking audience
questions taking political tests and
doing all sorts of different sort of
long-form content that we don't
typically do on the broadcast show and
one of the great ways to support us on
twitch is if you have an Amazon Prime
account Amazon lets you subscribe to us
with something called twitch Prime it
doesn't cost you anything because every
Amazon Prime member gets a free twitch
Prime subscription every month but it
counts as a paid subscription for us so
that's really great but here is a
warning about that from a someone who is
savvy with twitch take a listen to this
hey David this is ty Paul and I just
wanted to give you a quick heads-up
about twitch Prime in in that people
need to subscribe to that every month so
after every 30 days they'll have to go
back onto twitch and REE click that
subscription button whereas a regular
paid subscription on twitch prime not
excuse me not twitch prime just on
twitch yes will just automatically renew
and so again if you subscribe through
twitch prime you actually have to
physically go through the process of
clicking that subscribe button again in
30 days and every 30 days ongoing in
order to remain a subscriber to the
channel alright thanks oh thanks black
reco yep so let's say I mean I think
this is of course by design the idea of
giving people a twitch a free twitch
Prime subscription is that they do it
for a month and then they convert to a
fully paid membership which I would love
for people to do on twitch but the
reality is that a lot of people just
want to support us with that twitch
Prime subscription so this is something
we need to figure out obviously on
streams that I continue to do I can
remind people hey check your twitch
Prime status they expire automatically
every 30 days please resubmit
thing but you've got to click that Rhys
absque ribe button but I'm open to
hearing from people in the audience
about the best way to do this people
more familiar with twitch and who are on
there potentially a great source of
revenue for us but this automatic
expiring and having to manually renew I
think will be a challenge that we'll
have to sort of figure out and overcome
I want to hear from you about that in
the meantime follow me on twitch at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman hope you'll
join a live stream there for totally
different types of content than what
we're doing on our other platforms and I
also hope to see you on the bonus show
today we will be talking about a bunch
of different stuff including Ohio State
University wanting to trademark the word
V we will talk about more than 200,000
people signing a petition to rename
Trump Towers Street after Barack Obama
which is interesting and also more
research showing the promise of ecstasy
MDMA as a treatment for PTSD we've
covered this before on the show and I
wanted to get into it on today's bonus
show become a viewer of the bonus show
by becoming a member at join pakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show